hello look at this now I told you you
always have to start from this point
here this identity it's it's given now
the question is what can we do to it
together to twist into the shape okay
now before all we had to do was say when
X equal a number in our case 1 okay now
eventually probably you can see we are
going to do that eventually but this
isn't quite the right shape to get to
here when you just say x equals 1 right
so what do you have to do first well
where could you possibly go
I think the clue is all up here okay
that n minus 1 right that's very similar
for the one we just had right through to
the end ok
but the difference is what it's the
powers going down by one and for some
reason this numbers come out the front
now in what field topic of matter we've
looked at so far do you get a power that
reduces and then the coefficient comes
out the front answer differentiation
like this the first kind of
differentiation we learned right namely
the derivative of X to the power n right
that's NX to the N minus 1 that's us
isn't it ok so the question is well how
do I use it
yeah where are your studies I'm gonna
take both sides of this identity I'm
just going to differentiate both sides
ok so different [ __ ] this
now before we move on any further and
actually evaluate this this is the
reason why in this topic and in this
topic alone I totally advocate when you
get to your final HSC easier to fight
your way as far as you can here's why
okay a binomial theorem there's kind of
two you go back and look at the HSC
exams in three unit it's kind of two
versions of questions if you get the
binomial theorem okay you get really
simple ones like just tell me which
can't Fisher or what the coefficient is
for this term or whatever and they'll
come up in like questions one or two
really basic one or two marks okay you
only get those or there's no middle
ground
they just got jump straight to this is
really crazy hard you look at it and all
of the sort of people who in the state
just doing three enough but they're just
barely scraping by they gonna think yeah
right it's kind of you know what my
daughter did what you looked at my I
know is in preschool right and one of
the things that they they assess the
students on is their you know their
mental dexterity so they give them a
piece of paper with lines on it and they
say couple lines right so they're like
how straight key cut you kind of wavy
line so I'm holding my daughter's test
in my hand and this one's okay this
one's kind of like bit off and wasn't
quite there then she looked at this one
which is like most of the state looks a
question like this and they're like get
bad I'm gonna I'm gonna bother right and
it even gets worse even if you know what
to do I mean freezes look at this
you're like for real like super [ __ ] is
bad on its own when you add calculus to
it okay but you guys will be you'll be
different okay because we're gonna
finish this Tanya before the trial and
by the time it's your meeting of the HSC
you're gonna be sick to death these
questions because you're so good at them
okay so let's take this one bit at a
time
okay Fighting's gonna actually be worse
I'm did to you because you have trouble
with it they be like oh yeah these some
of the people who did it - just Pike on
it they sort of knew something okay
first differentiate left-hand side chain
rule right what do I get yeah
differentiate the outside
bring the power down reduce the power by
one okay
differentiate the inside which is just
one so that's fine okay let me get to
this bit and I admit it looks very
intimidating but all this means is it's
shorthand for a whole bunch of terms
it's the sum of all those terms okay but
in both directions differentiation and
integration right the derivative of a
sum is just the sum of all the
derivatives right you could take each
term individually and differentiate them
on their own so really I can sort of
forget about this guy right this is
actually equal to the sum are from 0 to
n of the derivative of all of these guys
ok I just differentiate each one
individually and it should come out in
the wash later okay so next ^ ah so I
should go back entries are entries are
that's just the constant it's a
coefficient it's just the number so I
can forget about it right this is my
ninja difference yet differentiates in
just the way I differentiate this one
right so I'm gonna get some from 0 to n
of n choose R times R X 1 that looks
suspicious doesn't it okay now look I've
got it in this form now I can say let X
equal 1 okay all for what it's worth
later on you know my number 2 can be any
number you like ok so you just choose
whatever value of x is appropriate okay
so what happens here
now my left-hand side turns into and
times 2 to the N minus 1 sorry okay what
are you getting the right hand side here
the sum from I equal 0
plus I'll put that holler at the front
because that's what's meant to be X
which is 110 power whatever and that's
just one right
tada it's not so bad like it's hardly
even that many wines okay so it does it
does look terrible and this this step is
kind of a leap okay but now that you
know it it won't be a leap next time